welcome back to the rich eisen show our
next guest
is uh one of the best in the business on
the defensive line it's gonna be his
second year
in indianapolis it is uh
going to be his sixth year in the
national football league he is deforest
buckner how are you sir
i'm doing well thank you for having me
again what's going on where where have
we found you
uh in your world post uh post mini camps
on summer break is that where you are
pretty much right now yeah
um i'm actually out in vegas right now
um what am i
working with my trainer mark hall um you
know he's based out here in vegas right
now
um yeah i mean me and uh eric armstead
dexter lawrence we've been getting some
work out here for the past week
i mean uh it's been 111 11 out
the average so it's been it's been hot
yes so you do
most of your workouts indoors then i
would imagine
on that front oh yeah part of it but we
we go outside for quite a bit what are
you doing
like geez i mean walk me through what
what a workout is with with uh
that trail what about yeah just doing
some uh
you know physician specific stuff uh you
know with
footwork you know doing some speed
footwork footwork stuff
uh you know bag drills you know as a
d-lineman
you know you can't get enough of
passwords drills so uh
you know doing doing some drills like
that you know some conditioning so
just a little bit of you know everything
what was it like playing last year
to forest now that you're through it
what was that like
it was a crazy experience uh you know
definitely the the crazy experience i've
ever had playing football in general you
know and not you know going to some
places not having any fans you know
during the covet
kobe uh kobe gear you would say uh it
was insane
um i honestly i felt like uh you know
sometimes it felt like it was a
scrimmage
instead of an actual game you know right
but you know the the just having the
fans
it's a big part of the game you know
there's they make a big difference
you know you feel that energy with with
the full stadium
compared to an empty stadium um yeah it
was it was hectic and then
and also you know just the camaraderie
and trying to build the team you know
what i mean it was hard
having to do all that social distancing
um
you know doing a lot of things virtual
um
yeah it just it definitely wasn't the
same no i know that and it seems that uh
you know things have definitely changed
on that front now i want to hit
hit hit this briefly with you here um
because we we hear so much about uh
players whether they're vaccinated or
they're not planning to get vaccinated
or they are and they're just learning
about it
where are you on that front deforest
yeah um so i actually uh me and my wife
we actually got vaccinated
um earlier in the off season um you know
it was
it was a big personal decision for us um
you know
especially for me you know doing a
little bit more research and finding out
you know if you're vaccinated you know
you're
most likely not to pass it along if you
were to so you know that some chance you
do end up getting it
um you you can't pass it along to
anybody and last year
um you know around you know thanksgiving
time
you know i i obviously i had cobin and i
missed the game
but if you know we weren't getting
tested every day i wouldn't have never
known i didn't have any symptoms
i was asymptomatic and um you know
that's
that was a really big selling point for
me was you know the ability of not being
able to pass it along to someone else
and you know causing them to get sick
and so uh
that was a really big reason for my wife
and i to you know the reason why we got
vaccinated also it was just
i mean going through all those protocols
testing every day
you know having that social distancing
the the virtual stuff
i mean wearing a mask every day in the
facility i mean i was just tired of it
you know what i mean i just wanted to go
about my daily life and try to have some
type of norm
you know enormous normalcy so that's why
i decided to get a vaccination
i mean you know there's obviously perks
and some setbacks
you know with the the rules and
regulations that the league's coming out
with with being vaccinated not being
vaccinated and
um i just thought you know just mentally
for me
it was the right decision for myself so
and again i know this is again personal
decision and
and something you've decided to do can
you walk me through what some of your
teammates
or others in the league are thinking
uh when they choose not to get
vaccinated and this is before the rules
uh just came out that might um
incentivize players to get the shot but
can you walk me through and some of the
fans who are who are wondering about
this
through all that deforest yeah um
i mean all i can say i mean really is
it's just a personal decision you know
what i mean
everybody has their own decision on what
they want to do um
you know it's you know a lot you know
some some people they don't like the
size they don't you know they don't know
everything
you know that's going to go into their
body um you know that people got to do
more research
more facts need to come out about
certain things i guess and um that's
their personal decision
you know what i mean i can't you know i
respect every every person's decision
whether they take
uh decide to get it not to you know
there's also people who
um you know who uh don't believe in
vaccinations in general you know what i
mean in modern medication which is
you know totally fine and i respected
the decision that they make
um so it's just a lot of factors you
know what i mean that goes in you know
for a guy's decision
um to to get vaccinated or not to get
vaccinated so
um i mean all i can say on my end is you
know i respect the decision they make
you know either whether they take it or
not and um it's
you know at the end of the day it's
everybody's personal decision and then
you know so best as you're telling as
you're calling in from
uh your personal workout spot in las
vegas right now with some of your
your nfl colleagues is is it going to be
set up in a way that you
and fellow fully vaccinated indianapolis
colts will have
one room and one weight room and one
spot on the bus or one specific bus and
one specific
floor in a hotel and and and your
not non-fully vaccinated teammates will
just have to
separately go about their business
similar to what you went through last
year that you didn't want to go through
again and
and then you'll eventually meet in a
locker room
on the road or at home is that literally
the way it might work best you can tell
right now yeah um i i honestly couldn't
tell you um you know i
you know i mean i guess when we report
back from training camp
after more of these rules come out and
and you know where you know the state
the the status of the team on you know
whether you know if we have you know a
lot of guys vaccinated or not vaccinated
um i mean i guess that's when we're
gonna find out the really the blueprint
and how the season going to go
and uh that's the big that's a big
question you know what i mean i'm i'm
sure a lot of
you know obviously all 32 teams are
going to be going through this
um and trying to you know figure out you
know what what their season is going to
look like with you know
how many guys that have actually or not
and and all of that so it's gonna be
it's definitely gonna be another
challenging and interesting year
but i can i imagine you you can't
compare now that you're fully vaccinated
with other of your teammates who are
being in a in a room like a film room or
weight room just like normal
like that's that that's got to feel
great like you never took that for
like we take that for credit back in the
day and definitely you know
definitely definitely yeah we doubt you
you definitely especially last year you
definitely
you know as a player you took those
little things for granted you know just
being in
the same locker room together um being
in the film room together
uh you know what i mean um you know just
being able to have that that little time
in between breaks where you know
you just you know just hanging out you
know what i mean spending time with each
other
uh just just a little those little
things you took it for granted for sure
and uh you know we definitely understand
how precious those times are and
um i mean i for me personally just being
able to not wear a mask into the
facility and seeing everybody's faces
every day
um you know for those that are you know
what i mean it makes a big difference
indianapolis colts defensive lineman
deforest buckner here on the rich eisen
show all right so it's going to
kind of be like old school for you first
two weeks of the 2021
campaign seahawks rams at home like you
noticed
yeah i mean like you just when you think
you're out they pull you back in the
forest
you know i know right i mean it's crazy
yeah i'm definitely gonna have uh
i'm definitely gonna be excited um you
know especially this year uh being able
to
you know face some teams in my um mild
division and also obviously face my
you know my former team so it's gonna be
it's gonna be exciting what's that gonna
feel like for you
it's a sunday night game whole country
settling in um
in uh in week um it looks like seven for
you
at the uh at the old stomping grounds
what's that gonna be like for you
do you think yeah it's going to be i
don't know it's going to be a real
feeling you know being able to
go back into that stadium um you know
where i spent the first four
years of my career um you know a lot of
ups and downs in that stadium obviously
but uh i mean just being able to be
around you know i i still
you know have a lot of niner fans you
know um that support me and
um i'm excited you know to go back to
see a lot of my old
you know my a lot of my friends you know
i built a lot of relationships there um
so it's going to be interesting coming
in
playing in a game there and uh going
into the the visitors locker room for
sure it's gonna be
it's gonna be weird but uh it's gonna be
a lot of fun and let's talk about your
current team here
uh week three right off the bat i mean
you got you got two
former division uh games and then
your first game on the road is going to
be at the titans
julio now is in that mix clearly that's
not going to be somebody you need to
mark but obviously getting to tannehill
to make sure
he doesn't mark julio will be in your
bailiwick what are what
what was how did the the jones
acquisition by
the titans go down in your locker room
deforest
yeah mommy i i really talked to the guys
but you know guys haven't really been
talking about it much but
okay i mean it was good for them was a
good addition for them you know um julio
is a great player
um obviously one of the best you know
receivers
um to ever play the game and um
you know kudos to them they had another
weapon on offense uh
you know it's it's gonna be fun to watch
them during throughout the season
uh you know going against them you know
um twice a year is gonna be
you know a lot more fun you know i mean
uh the bigger the challenge you know
what i mean
the more interesting the game gets and i
love it you know i love going against
the best and um you know to be the best
got to be the best and um they're
they're one of the best teams in the
league right now and
um you know like you said gotta get the
t if i get tana hill
i mean the ball can't get to julio so
it's gonna be fun
and of course your team had a major
acquisition
this non-playing season in the
quarterback what's your first
impressions of
carson wentz best you can tell deforest
over the first few weeks here
yeah i love the guy um you know i
i don't see you know all the the things
that they were talking about you know in
philly whatever was going on last year
or you know the type of player they were
saying he was or the mental state
i mean he's he came in you know ready to
work
um he's a man on a mission you know he's
he's reached out to
you know majority of the guys on the
team um you know i've
spent quality time i had you know my
wife and i had you know his
him and his wife and their daughter um
they're you know their daughter's about
three
three days younger than my son and you
know we had them over for dinner
uh before we left you know come back to
the west coast i mean it's
i mean i mean carson's a great great guy
on and off the field
um you know he's i can see the the the
leader that he is
um he's definitely a leader of men
especially at the you know quarterback
position which you need to be in
um you know i'm i'm all i mean i can't
wait to see what he does
this year um you know what i mean uh you
know uh
being able to have that fresh start
that's what i think he just needed you
know he needed to get out of you know
get out of philly gotta get a fresh
start i mean he's got a great o-line in
front of him to keep him upright
so he can and he's got a lot of weapons
on offense to dish the ball to
so it's it's going to be really fun to
see him come back this year what
what do you mean by he reached out to
everybody walk me through that he called
everybody yeah like
i mean he's he's reached out to multiple
guys you know when he got signed
um you know he texted about you know uh
several guys on the team
um you know what i mean me include you
know including me
you know he reached out to me and um you
know i was able to you know connect with
him a little bit um
texting back and forth you know what i
mean about just you know just a bunch of
you know stuff going on go you know
through the year
i mean our interests and stuff like that
you know i'm i like i like hunting
obviously he's big into hunting and
um you know we talked about that a
little bit and um you know and then you
know it just built that relationship
until you know otas when we saw each
other in person and you know obviously i
had him over the house you know for
dinner and stuff like that so i mean
you know he's just a very you know he's
a team guy um you know a great teammate
and you know i i'm just you know i'm
excited to see him play this year
so what is a uh uh uh a once play date
at the buckners look like
what was that like with the once play
date what was that my uh
you know they're both it's funny because
uh they're both they're both about the
same they are the same age right another
three days apart
so being able to actually see my son
with uh you know
a kid that you know his age and seeing
them go through the same things was
hilarious
um you know what i mean they're getting
into everything
obviously you know just babbling and uh
i mean i might my son was uh he's he's
in the face of throwing everything so
yeah
he was she was throwing some things and
i was like man yo she's trying to tell
him like hey you gotta calm down you
know what i mean she's
you know it's different you know playing
with boys and girls oh yeah you got to
be careful
girls are more advanced than boys boys
are boys are idiots compared to girls
you know
i've got two i've got two boys and a
younger girl and she seriously she
she she runs rings around him and i love
my boys yeah but uh
so what do you mean he's throwing
everything like everything because my
one of my sons i caught him uh early on
trying to dribble a marble in the house
like literally anything that's around so
i imagine what happened yeah my son
would probably try to eat the marble
he's you know everything's
you know he's trying to taste it i mean
obviously you know
every toy it doesn't matter what if it's
a toy you know your phone
um me and my wife actually just had to
get new phones recently just because he
shattered both of ours
great you know you just like to grab
stuff and then look at it and throw it
you know try to see what it does you
know what i mean and it's just funny
it's a funny stage watching them right
now happy father's day to you deforest i
hope you have a happy
career hey man last one before you go
speaking of man child
uh talk to me about darius leonard and
being in front of him
and and taking a responsibility to clear
the decks for him
uh as you as you may be you know stop
the run on the way to the past like what
what what is that like for you to have
him patrolling right behind you
the farmer yeah i mean i mean it makes
my job a lot easier having a guy like
him behind me
um you know uh you know if i make a
mistake i just got to go fast and make
it fast for him because i know he's
gonna clean it up
you know what i mean and especially in
the run game um you know if i
if i i'm supposed to be in the b gap if
i get reached
i know he'll be there to clean it up
because you know obviously he's
one hell of a talent um you know that
his athleticism i mean his speed at the
other linebacker position is
unreal i mean he's a sideline sideline
linebacker i mean
he'll come around quick um you know he
and and just the energy that he brings
every single day
i mean it's not just on game days it's
every day you know what i mean and
um having a guy like him on the team is
just i mean
it's it's a big game changer for us you
know he's a great teammate
great leader i mean i like i said before
it just makes my job a lot easier
um you know it's fun being out there
playing with them so
uh a guy like darius is just he's one
he's one of one
well yeah you know and by the way
another one of one that i keep hearing
about
as referred to that as well is another
oregon duck who's playing quarterback
out here in los angeles
how about that how about the duck
sending a guy to the nfl who's turning
into a unicorn at the quarterback spot
yeah deforest definitely right justin
herbert is
i mean i remember the first game i
watched them when i was uh you know i
turned
the duck game on one day um and i was
just like man this kid's gonna be
special
and you know what i mean he yeah what
he's doing at the quarterback position
i mean especially his rookie year coming
in i mean i'm it's exciting to see you
know where his career
goes yeah oregon's a quarterback school
right that's what you got
it's starting to be yesterday i bet
deforest thanks for
the time letting us catch up with you uh
stay safe be well
happy father's day happy father's day i
appreciate you thank you
right back at you that's deforest
buckner one of the best from the
indianapolis colts here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here